[Music]
at least she didn't get her hair wet
right girls
[Music]
that's called quake in the pool it's the
latest summer challenge white people
been quaking the pool since they were
the only ones allowed in them quake the
pool break the pool quake the pool there
you get it but it's not just pools that
can be quick you can quake anything
[Music]
[Applause]
pay for the jacuzzi cannonball
he went with a can opener
probably tours Gooch this video confirms
two stereotypes White's can't jump but
thankfully they can all swim
I'd suggest wearing some aqua Sox next
time some traction I tried to jump over
my infinity pool Mo Money mo problems
you